okay so working on the outside that's
the part we want to work on we want to
emphasize this one half okay
one hand is doing it
this hand goes here
and it's going to i keep here so it gets
palmed down and into the perpendicular
boom
right here here
do it one hand but we're doing it two
hand but it's the same
see it's still gonna do the same adhere
so you never lose the knot
you're always on the knot
okay
and you would wait for that technically
you'd wait for that opening so he feels
the block
hey maybe he comes up
he feels the block
comes up
oh you follow the up
and then into depth where the disarm
would be okay
okay
boom
you can't get it there so he comes
around
and you follow his arm comes around
okay just drilling though you're
focusing on this hand
he's not coming up
i'm
doing it to his hands
[Music]
but this time this is the keynote this
has stays
on
stage
[Music]
oh
okay
stay on that's what you're drilling go
okay so as as you're working
this basic
foam
you still have your mind so you don't
want to do this in here
okay he's going to punch me with the
other hand he's going to shove me
backwards
or you can do a knife pass
so like in tight like this you'll grab
it with his other hand and i don't have
the knife and he stabs them together
okay or you could have two knives at
least as we know the other knife
so you still your why is still weapon
weapon range
oh i'll hit all his weapons okay so i'm
not gonna move over here where you can
punch me
or stab me or knife pass
so i'm always at the
distance of those weapons
secondly
i'm always taking his ball and so he's
not here and he's standing straight up
so i have to do the same movement but i
have to take
which way oh i can only use those two
position patterns from inward or back
outward so here i go back outward
all right boom back outward
check
my outwards
[Music]
you're doing your non-contestation
so the knife is leading
leading into the movement
with my non-contestation
[Music]
so when you work on this part
do it with all of this stuff
[Music]
because what you're doing is you're
setting up a dilemma dude do you want to
hold your weapon or do you want to hold
your balance
okay that's his dilemma
i have his violence
let's say i don't have this balance you
see
and i try to get his weapon
he can move any old way to stop the
prime
do you get it yes
so look how it wants to go this way you
see that if you move around this way
that's no longer the right angle
goes around
there it goes okay
so right here
i have the balance
and he has to move that way if he stops
moving
so you're moving to keep those balls and
that allows me to take the knife
[Music]
okay here we go
okay so again we we have the basic
bone pop basic turn it to its extreme
probably down to the right angle i can
use different parts of my body to do the
prying
and the tip then we moved a little bit
more advanced we pay attention to the
high key adhesion
pay attention
right here so you're not coming off the
weapon that won't be how you use it that
will not be how you find a disarm
okay
um
then
the tendency is the knife will preoccupy
your feathers your mind you come around
here and you fight like this okay but
then it punches you or stabs you or
something else happens together
arm
or even knife passes because you're over
here around with that thing okay
remember
that you're fighting
the archer and not the arrow okay
so
you still have all your aikido
strategy and tactics kazushi center
connection
and setting up jiu jitsu dilemmas that's
all you're doing okay
because
worst case let's say i get there
i couldn't get it i'll pop them
in the face
it's fine
all right i can't i can't get oh and i
just hit the knife
the knife
then i'll find the disarm down here
there's plenty of things to work on
what you have to work on in the drills
don't let the knife preoccupy you
don't let the knife fetter your mind
movement is free
and that's going to come into issue
because now what we're going to do is
start shrinking things
first thing you realize that you start
shrinking things
the right angle at any
vector
to the outward vector
will suffice
i don't have to go all the way and
complete the grip to its
most compromised position
you can't do it right here
so if i can do it right here
then i can do it in any one i can do
here i can do it here i can do it here i
can do it here dude here doing here do
here here you get it okay
so as i as i'm trying to shrink these
things in my drill i'm going to be
closer now don't step out like that just
bring the hand there and the hand comes
[Music]
and i can move
but i won't move a lot
in other words i'm not going to traverse
the knot like you were doing
a small moment
[Music]
me
they can deal with his body
uh by being on the zone sanctuary you
can deal with his body with being with
his hemi
you can deal with his body by moving
right so
come out
there
it doesn't matter
but small
smaller
okay okay okay so this drill is to make
sure that uh
you're not getting stuck on the knife
okay
so i'm going to be small i have the body
and i'm going to detect it
you could you could do any technique
okay
it doesn't matter so
if whatever it gives you so the first
one you came through the second way he
stayed still you see if you stay still
you're going to be open to what you're
going to be able to strike so you go
slow you know a lot to see
not drawing my attention
though you have let's say you could look
at it this way i'm trying to make my
technique small take the knife out
okay he has a time and i'm trying to
make my technique
happen
in that amount of time trying to make my
disarm happen
in that amount of time
[Music]
okay